Let's go next to our caller from the six six
one area code who's calling today from six
six one.
A David, a long time viewer here from Lancaster,
California.
And I just had a quick question for you.
Sure.
The rhetoric that Trump and his campaign has
put forth since his election, since he started
running in 2015, I feel as though it's directly
led to a rise in deaths of despair in America.
Alcohol, liver disease, suicide, drug overdose.
And also, just overall, violent crimes, hate
crimes, things like that.
And I actually wanted to know if you had any
thoughts on that.
Any will.
No, I have no particular thought.
I mean, so there's a couple different sides
to that.
So depths of despair often are related to
economic circumstances.
And certainly it would be a counterpoint to
the idea that before Corona virus, things
were better than ever.
Because if things were better than ever, you
would not expect many of these deaths of despair
to be on the increase.
Now, in terms of the hate crimes and crimes
targeting religious minorities or ethnic minorities
or whatever the case may be.
I've said before, I don't think Trump has
created racists or xenophobes.
And whether Trump is personally racist or
xenophobic is less relevant.
What matters is Trump has made existing racists
and xenophobes more comfortable to be out
in public with their views and has emboldened
them.
And so it's also not particularly surprising.
But I think the deaths of despair are sort
of a different phenomena than that than some
of these hate crimes and other violence.
I appreciate the answer and they come on the
show and hope you have a good day.
All right.
Thank you.
Yes, that that was the audio quality.
There was brutal.
I apologize for that.